before the Seven Kingdoms before the
iron throne
there was a Dorne twelve thousand years
ago the first man crossed a land bridge
from essos to here of course there were
men so they soon broke it then while
their cousins to the north built
kingdoms the dornish squabbled over land
water and wives
for centuries
until nymeria a warrior princess in
essos she led a fleet of ten thousand
ships across the narrow sea to Dorne
almost all of the petty Lords made it
clear that she wasn't welcome
all but one Morse of house Martel
he saw in here as strength to match any
man including his rivals
after she accepted his marriage offer
she set fire to her ships you have to
wait two years until the next episode of
House of the Dragon so now is the
perfect time for you to listen to the
audiobook on which house of the Dragon
is based and you can listen to it now
for free that's right you can listen to
Fire and Blood audiobook for free it's a
Targaryen history book on which house of
the Dragon is based written by George R
Martin it goes from aegon's Conquest
until the end of the dance of the
Dragons which will also be the end of
House of the Dragon you can now listen
to it for free with horrible trial using
our link which you can find in the
description of this video all you have
to do is go to the description click the
link sign up for free audible trial and
choose Fire and Blood audiobook go and
listen to a long and Rich Targaryen
history including the current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
for 50 leads the coast was bright as day
and in the burning light princess
nymeria named Morse Martel the prince of
Dorne in the style of her people
Dorne would be her home
or her grave
for many years nymeria and Morse waged
war against all rivals the jordanes
blackmonths core Guiles and even the
mighty house Ironwood they sent no fewer
than six self-styled Kings to the wall
in golden chains after Morris fell in
battle nymeria took command of his
armies and United Dorne in two years she
ruled for 27 more and Doshi marred again
those husbands were little more than
counselors and consorts
Dorne was nymeria and nymeria was Dorne
she survived a dozen attempts on her
life put down two rebellions and threw
back two invasions and when at last she
died her eldest child succeeded her her
daughter not her son and Dorne followed
her because nymeria had proven that
women were equal to men if not better
unbowed unbent unbroken the words of
house Martel the words of Dorne men may
forget but women always remember when we
were divided nymeria United us when we
were invaded Maria defended us
Westeros has Mighty Rivers but none of
them compare to the roin it is said that
there is no stream or puddle in Western
esses but drains to Mother roin no doubt
an exaggeration
until one sees the river at its widest a
man in the center can't see ashore to
either side the greatest of mother
roin's children were the roiner a
civilization is ancient and Grand as old
geese Fishers Traders Scholars workers
of wood Stone and metal the Rhino raised
their elegant cities from the headwaters
of the Rhine down to her mouth each
Lovelier than the last for many
centuries the Rhino lived in relative
peace when Invaders swept down from the
hills the royner woman and man were Don
Silver Scaled Armor Fish Head Helms tall
Spears and turtle shell Shields if the
enemy did not laugh themselves away it
was said that mother royne would whisper
the enemy's secrets to her children and
the roinish Wizards could raise watery
walls to drown their foes whatever magic
the Ruiner may have had it wasn't enough
when Valyrian colonists first arrived
the Rhino embraced them for all men were
welcome to share the Bounty of mother
Roy perhaps a water people should have
been more cautious of strangers who
exalted Fire and Blood Legend has it
that one day the valyrians netted and
butchered one of the giant turtles the
royner held sacred as a result thousands
were killed or enslaved cities and towns
were burned drowned and rebuilt in these
wars the valerians emerged as Victorious
more often than not the princes of the
Roy new cities fiercely proud of their
independence fought alone whilst the
Valyrian colonies aided one another
eventually the roinish princess ceased
the squabbling and United behind prince
garan who led the largest army essos had
ever seen against a hundred thousand
Valyrian colonists a hundred war
elephants and three dragon Lords
burned but thousands more sheltered in
the shallows of the river whilst the
roinish Wizards raised enormous water
spouts against the first dragons roanish
archers brought down two of the Dragons
whilst the third fled wounded and
thereafter the Ruiner named Garen the
great but mother valyria proved just as
caring as mother Roy when Garen the
great marched his Army against volantis
300 Valyrian dragons descended from the
sky tens of thousands burned whilst
others rushed into the river but the
fires burned so hot that the water
boiled and turned to steam Garen the
great was captured alive and made to
watch as valyrians butchered every last
man so many that their blood turned the
great Harbor of volantis red as far as
the eye could see then they forced Garen
to watch as they marched on his own City
and enslaved all the women and children
his army had left behind the singers
claimed that Prince Garen called out
mother Roy to curse
and she in turn flooded the city with
foul Waters and a damp fog that caused
the skin of the valyrians to harden and
crack and thus was born grayscale
few afflictions are more feared than
grayscale and far past the point of
Reason a legend calls it Prince garin's
curse after an ancient Eastern Prince
whom the valyrians hung in a cage and
forced to watch the immolation of his
City and people as his City burned under
dragon flame this Prince called on his
God for vengeance and a thick fog of
foul humors Rose from the ruin to
smother the valyrians with grayscale and
if diseases could be cooled down by the
vengeful we'd have no Health in the
world
more likely the disease predates the
valyrians entirely confined to some
remote region of essos and only spread
throughout the world once the valyrians
linked the continent with robes and
Dragons
fearing a similar fate another roinish
ruler princess naneria led her own
people into every ship skiff and Ralph
they had and fled essos eventually after
much hardship they landed in sunswept
and bone dry Dawn
unbowed unbent Unbroken
the words of house Martel
a promise to our enemies and a challenge
to our lovers
thousands of years ago the warrior Queen
nymeria crossed into Dorne from essos
fleeing the dragonlords of Validia
after she landed she burned her ships
all ten thousand of them so no cowards
could slink home
what a woman dornish in spirit before
she ever was in flesh
she was lucky to London Dorne where
powerful women are not locked away in
seps and the beds of old men
my ancestor Morris Martell saw her and
desired her and proved that where armies
fail a tongue may succeed wedding his
strength to hers his spear to her son
they subdued all his Rivals together
after the tradition of her people house
Martel then ruled Dorne as princes not
Kings unless the eldest child was a
daughter for unlike the rest of Westeros
our loyalty isn't commanded by a [ __ ]
we follow a prince or a princess Martel
just the same do you two years until
season 2 is a long period but you can
still stay in the house of the Dragon
World by listening to Fire and Blood
audiobook for free house of the Dragon
is based on Fire and Blood book and
covers the entire Targaryen history
starting from aegon the Conqueror and
his Conquest as well as maker the cruel
and other legendary targaryens including
the current and future events of House
of the Dragon go and listen to it for
free with horrible trial using our Link
in the description
foreign